let's talk about what's been happening
in Iran
[Music]
ever since 22 year old Masa amini died
in police custody back in September
Iranians have been protesting with women
and young people leaving the calls for
change as soon as they started they were
calling for the downfall of the regime
we had you know women in taking off
their head scars cutting their hair
chanting very radical slogans
Iran's leaders are calling the protests
riots and say they're being orchestrated
by foreign enemies authorities have
tried everything in their playbook to
respond ranging from using lethal Force
against protesters to arresting human
rights Defenders and protesters and
activists to handing down death
sentences to putting out propaganda and
misinformation and ignoring them and
calling for their ends but they've not
gone away so why have the protests
lasted this long and have they changed
anything in Iran
let's take it back to September 13th
Masa amini was visiting the capital
Tehran when she was arrested by the
morality police for what they called her
inappropriate attire basically they
thought she wasn't dressed right and
Iran's got strict laws about that which
we'll get to in a bit
they took her to a Detention Center the
police later released this edited
footage of her there showing her talking
to an officer and then collapsing
foreign
[Music]
suggest she fell into a coma before
being transferred to a hospital three
days later she was dead a Coroner's
report said her death was linked to an
underlying disease her family though say
that's just not true they say she didn't
have any health problems and that she'd
been beaten by the police
now as soon as the news about masa's
death spread people started protesting
first outside the hospital in Tehran
where she died and then at her funeral
in her hometown of sakez in Northwestern
Iran
this year shock of a 22 year old woman a
daughter a woman a sister going out in
the street and not coming back home
alive the reason that that was the straw
that broke the camel's back or that's
why people came to the street was
because in so many ways the case of NASA
was what represented the systemic
problem with enforcement of compulsory
hijab laws in Iran now these laws date
back to the early 1980s after Iran's
Islamic revolution
that's when the monarchy was overthrown
and replaced by the system of government
Iran has today
[Applause]
by the way the hijab laws are not just
about women having to wear a headscarf
they're effectively a conservative dress
code that all women and girls over nine
are required to follow in public the
punishments for violating the laws have
changed over the years but in the 90s it
became a criminal offense that could
lead to a prison sentence the morality
police in their current form have been
the main agency in forcing the laws
since 2006. I know many women who have
had personal experiences what happens is
they are approached by these officials
that operate from a van in various parts
of the city and they are told that they
are not dressed appropriately they are
taken to a police facility where they
are either fined or they are put through
an education course about what they
should be wearing when they're in public
and usually they are allowed out with a
warning the first time that they're
detained but it's important to
understand is that the compulsory hijab
laws impact ever every aspect of a
woman's life in Iran because the
criteria for what constitutes
appropriate her job is completely
arbitrary so you might be someone who
believes in her job and choose to wear
it in a certain way and still get in
trouble or you might not believe in it
and get in trouble this was one issue
that came up following the death of
Master Gino amini that she actually
looked quite impeccably dressed by
today's standard she was wearing a long
black robe she was wearing a long black
scarf compared to a whole lot else that
we have seen in you know Tehran streets
over the last few years that was pretty
good hijab and all of this helps to
explain why the protests after masa's
death are not just about the mandatory
hijab laws but also about something
bigger
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
at her grave site people started
chanting Gian Azadi which is the Kurdish
equivalent of woman life Freedom the
slogan was picked up because it really
resonated very much with the essence and
the spirit of the protest movement which
ties the liberty of the population at
large to the liberty of women there has
been this sort of understanding that
unless women are free unless women are
given Liberties
um nobody else will have those Liberties
either people have come to the
conclusion that there is absolutely no
way that this regime can change its
behavior and there is no way that it can
reform itself and they are quite clear
and they are quite persistent in their
demands they want the regime gone since
September brights groups have recorded
more than a thousand protests across the
country in over 150 cities some of the
biggest have been in Kurdistan Province
where Masa was from there have also been
a lot in and around Tehran here's this
example where school girls are shouting
at a school official
foreign
in the Southeast one of the poorest
provinces in Iran workers going on
strike have also been a big part of the
protest movement including shopkeepers
and oil and steel workers
[Music]
the situation has been intense for a
very long time in Iran there are several
grievances political economic issues the
issue of women personal freedom
the intensification and escalation of
the pressure by the so-called morality
release in the public spaces so the
situation was tense and it was brewing
now the government is trying to shut
these protests down and they're blaming
foreign enemies countries like the US
and Israel
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
now it's always hard to get a clear
picture of what's going on in Iran but
the evidence points to a brutal
Crackdown by Security Forces
foreign
Us and other human rights groups have
documented use of excessive and lethal
Force against protesters they're using
um pellet guns shotguns even in some
cases cold and other kinds of weapons
against protesters hundreds of Iranians
have been killed the government says
it's more than 200 since September
including members of the security forces
although they don't break down the
numbers but the UN and human rights
groups outside of Iran say the numbers
killed are higher
one group says 490 protesters have been
killed including dozens of children
along with more than 60 members of the
security forces
and then there are all the arrests more
than 18 thousand according to rights
groups that includes activists
journalists and well-known musicians
like too much salehi
shervin hajipur who wrote the protest
movement's unofficial answers
[Music]
and some of those arrested are facing
charges that carry the death penalty
rights groups estimate that at least 12
people have now been sentenced to death
and we know of at least two executions
that have already taken place
so there's been this big Crackdown and
at the same time there are signs the
government is under pressure but how
much they're really feeling it well
that's hard to tell the attorney general
has said that Parliament and the
Judiciary are reviewing the hijab laws
and are expected to announce their
opinion soon
but whether that represents any kind of
significant concession is part of the
debate I think this is just an
extraction mechanism why the Islamic
Republic themselves to distract Global
and domestic attention from the bigger
issues let's not forget nobody is just
chanting on the streets in Iran and
asking for abolishment of your job
people are asking for a regime change so
people's demands are bigger they've also
been mixed messages over what's going on
with the morality of police there were
reports about Iran shutting them down
based on slightly confusing comments by
the Attorney General State media then
said he was misinterpreted and there's
been no confirmation from the government
that anything has changed but at the
same time some people in Iran are saying
the morality police have been less
visible than normal over the last few
weeks
now Iran has seen waves of protests
before and they haven't led to any
significant changes so is anything
different this time around well no
According to some people who reckon
these protests will eventually fizzle
out too they will die down eventually
because the society will not back
insecurity uh come in with the rioters
in the streets but others are convinced
that there really is something different
going on this time around
I think it's the first time where we see
a lot of different groupings both
socially ethnically religiously people
really coming together and expressing
their demand for bringing down the
Islamic Republic
most important
outcome of this is
the
loss of fear of the government and
Iranian people are no longer defining
State as this Untouchable absolute power
that they cannot confront
regardless of where this protests go and
how they end they have they have turned
the page and they've changed the
conversation Ordinary People along with
activists and public figures
have and are continuing to create an
alternative image an alternative reality
of what life
could look like
[Music]
we did an episode last year about Iran's
presidential election check it out if
you want to understand more about how
president raisy came to power and the
way Iran's political system works
[Music]